hey guys this is vidi with max sec and
today we're gonna be comparing the
brand-new 2019 macbook air to the $1300
13 inch MacBook Pro all right let's get
this box off and here we are we have the
beautiful gold macbook air this is a
color that you cannot get on the MacBook
Pro really really nice looking gold
let's get rid of this oh yeah nice very
very nice there goes that and we can
also take off a little film in here just
like that nice and fresh get that back
into the box alright and we'll get rid
of the box as well so as far as design
both of them look really nice they're
both really similar in size as you guys
can see both really close they have the
same all aluminum chassis all the way
around they look really really good
except if you look from the side angle
the MacBook Air actually has a wedge
shape compared to a slate shape a very
flat slate shape on the MacBook Pro so
that's one big difference and on the
side here we have one headphone jack and
on the other side we've got two
Thunderbolt three ports on both the
MacBook Pro and the MacBook Air and the
MacBook Air is actually a little bit
thicker at the thickest points of both
of these Mac books but on the front end
it's actually thinner than the MacBook
Pro now I have both of them turned over
and they look basically identical except
on the MacBook Pro it looks like the
vents are a little bit bigger whereas
it's a little bit slimmer this van right
here is slimmer on the MacBook Air and
just like on the MacBook Pro the hinge
opens up really easily which is
something awesome with Apple Mac books
compared to Windows laptops and it looks
like we have the same kind of overall
layout right here we have a nice big
trackpad we have the whole keyboard
layout here but the MacBook Pro actually
has the touch bar something that you
don't get on the MacBook Air
however the MacBook Air does get touch
ID and its built-in right into the power
button and again we've got the speaker
grilles on both sides just like on the
MacBook Pro and one thing that's
different is the hinge the notch on the
hinge here
has this kind of curve to it and
actually cuts out the whole front end
whereas you actually just get a notch in
the corner on the MacBook Pro this is
very interesting and this is a trademark
that we used to get on the old MacBook
Airs it looks like Apple followed it
through with the new models as well and
another difference we see right here is
that the MacBook Airs trackpad is
actually slightly smaller than the one
on the MacBook Pro now I really love
large trackpads because it gives you a
lot of free movements right here
compared to Windows laptops especially
have very small trackpad so that's
pretty nice now the final difference is
actually a pretty big one on the MacBook
Air the keyboard actually slopes
downwards so you guys can see that the
MacBook Pro at the top is actually lower
than the MacBook Air and the near the
front the MacBook Pro is higher so you
definitely get a nice downward slope on
the MacBook Air and what this is gonna
do is it's gonna give you a better
typing experience it's gonna be more
comfortable to type on the MacBook Air
whereas on the MacBook Pro your palms
might actually dig into the edge of the
MacBook Pro and be a little bit
uncomfortable over time and with that
let's set it up and here we have the
touch ID setup let's set this up really
quick it scans surprisingly quick on
this it's probably the fastest there you
go it's done the fastest touch ID setup
you'll ever see and both of these have
touch ID so it's really really
convenient and something that we didn't
get last year on either of these Mac
books is true tone now true tone adjust
the white balance of the display to
match your surroundings so if we have
some of these tungsten lights like this
yellow in here in that little one there
it might affect the color in the
environment and this is gonna compensate
for that and change it so it looks paper
white all the time so as you guys can
see on this screen right here when I
click this it turns it off and it
becomes really blue it kind of simulates
the difference so this is really really
nice for reading and doing other stuff
like that let's quickly talk about the
differences between the function keys
and the touch bar with the function keys
you have access to all these settings
like the brightness we have the volume
controls we have the keyboard
backlighting right here
we have access to all of our windows
everything right here at all times
especially the Escape key while on the
touch bar you actually have to hit this
arrow first to get access to those same
keys and then you have to click the X
button to show the Escape key and then
the FN key shows all the f' buttons and
all this stuff you don't have access to
everything at once like you do with the
function keys however you can customize
this and add a bunch of different stuff
like different apps can add different
shortcuts and you can see different tabs
in Safari and all this other stuff now
one of the biggest differences between
both of these Mac books is that the
MacBook Pro has a much better display it
has P 3 wide color gamut support so it
actually has about 25% more colors than
100% srgb while the MacBook Air does not
have that it's not that color accurate
so if you're a photo editor you
definitely want to be going with the
MacBook Pro for the more color accurate
display and another big difference is
display brightness the MacBook Pro gets
500 nits while the MacBook Air has
around 350 so it's definitely a lot
dimmer it's not as bright as the MacBook
Pro as you guys can see right now so now
let's jump into a quick speaker test to
see which one sounds better let's start
with the MacBook Air
[Music]
okay
[Music]
okay first of all I can hear more volume
on the MacBook Pro already and it does
sound like ass a wider soundstage so far
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so the voice definitely sounds more
clear on the MacBook Pro I can tell
right away let's get into some more
bassy part of the song
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
okay and on this one yep and there's
more bass on the MacBook Pro as well so
overall the bullets sound really good
but I could definitely tell that the
MacBook Pro sounds a little bit better
more bass but both of these sounds so
much better than a lot of Windows
laptops out there so you really can't go
wrong and finally let's finish off with
the performance
now the 2019 MacBook Air comes with a
dual-core processor while the MacBook
Pro gets a quad core and while it's only
a 1.4 gigahertz quad core it's actually
really really powerful so let's start
off with Geekbench for CPU test so we
got the results back and we can see that
the MacBook Pro is much much more
powerful than the MacBook Air not only
are we getting over a thousand more
single core score but on multi-core
we're getting more than double more than
double the score than the MacBook Air so
just from this you're paying two hundred
dollars more for the MacBook Pro and
you're getting more than double the
multi-core performance it's really
really impressive and we just ran the
graphics test as well and we're getting
almost two and a half times more
graphics performance on the MacBook Pro
which is insane so after comparing all
that we can definitely say that the
MacBook Pro is the better value
considering the better display the
bigger trackpad the much much better
performance but is there any reason to
buy the MacBook Air why should someone
buy the MacBook Air if they could just
pay $200 more for the MacBook Pro well
first of all the MacBook Air does get
two hours more rated battery life it's
rated for twelve hours instead of ten
and that's because the performance is
definitely a lot lower but the MacBook
Pro does get brighter so if you're gonna
be using your MacBook Pro at maximum
brightness you might see an even bigger
difference in battery life between these
two machines and another reason is that
it does come in gold so if you really
really want the gold color you can get
the MacBook Air which you can't get on
the MacBook Pro and of course the
MacBook Air comes with the regular
function keys so if you absolutely can't
stand the touch bar you can choose the
MacBook Air and you can get those
function keys and finally the MacBook
Airs keyboard slopes downward so it is
gonna have a more comfortable typing
experience so if you're a writer most
likely you're gonna
the MacBook Air for the better battery
life and the more comfortable typing
experience thanks for watching guys if
you enjoyed this comparison tap that
like button and click the circle above
to subscribe thanks for watching and
we'll see you in the next video
[Music]